While we're looking at the person class, we didn't implement the
unfriend method when we refactored our code. But now you know how
to remove items from an array list. So let me see. If
I want to remove a person, nonfriend. what if I try getting
the name of nonfriend, going through the list to find its index,
and then removing that index? Is there anything wrong with this? Refactoring
to save an array list of the friends names was a step
in the right direction, but not enough. If I have two friends
with the same name, I wouldn't know which one to remove. In
fact, I can't even tell if I have the same friend in
here twice right now. I shouldn't just be storing a list of
the friends' names, I should be storing a list of the person
object associated with each friend. So let's refactor again I'll make my
ArrayList of String that I called friends before into an ArrayList of
Person. Now I'll have to fix the way I initialize it in
the constructor. And let's look at that implementation of the getFriends method
with the separator. Now I need to actually get the name
out of the friend stored at this position. I'll show you
what happens if I don't do that. Whenever I try to
print out the result of getFriends, instead of printing the person's name,
it's printing the class, and this weird jumble of symbols. Right
now, the array list to string method doesn't know how to make
a string representation of a person. So it just prints the
reference. These symbols make sense to the computer, but not to people.
So to avoid that mess, in the getFriends
method, I'll get the name from the friend, and
add that And I'll do it in both
spots. Can you finish the rest of this refactoring?